البقاء على قيد الحياة أمر غير عادي ، ليس أقله
لأنها عانت من ثلاث مجاعات على مدار
قرن من الزمان وكلهم يلومون
الكرملين على أننا
نأكل نبات الزيزفون ليندن أوراق ونباتات القراص التي
اعتدنا عليها لطحن هذه النباتات البرية وتحويلها إلى
أزهار ونأكلها
وهي في الثالثة عشرة من عمرها.
مات أخي وأخته في أسوأ مجاعة جماعية في أوكرانيا ، حيث
تورمت ساقاي في هولوديمور ،
وتورمت ذراعي ، كنت مريضًا جدًا لدرجة أنني اعتقدت أنني سأموت
في أوائل الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي بناءً على أوامر جوزيف ستالين ،
تم تجريد المزارعين الأوكرانيين
من كل الحبوب التي ينتجونها لإطعام
موسكو.  التصنيع:
أطفال صغار يموتون من الجوع
تم نقلهم إلى شاحنة حفروا
حفرة كبيرة وألقوا بهم جميعًا في
أوكرانيا بعد 11 شهرًا من
الغزو الروسي الأخير ،
ثلاثة من أحفادها هم جنود
يقاتلون القوات الروسية لأن
الرئيس الروسي لا يصدق ذلك  أوكرانيا
موجودة ،
وتجدر الإشارة إلى أن أوكرانيا
لم يكن لديها في الواقع تقاليد مستقرة لإقامة
دولة حقيقية ، ادعى بوتين أن هجوم روسيا
على العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف قد فشل
العام الماضي يعتقد العديد من الأوكرانيين أنهم
يقاتلون محاولة أخرى للإبادة الجماعية ،
ويجلس قادة ومنظمي الإبادة الجماعية في نفس الموقف.  مكاتب في
نفس المكان في وسط هذه الأحداث
هي موسكو والهدف من الدمار
هو أوكرانيا كدولة
تقول الحكومة الأوكرانية إن آلاف
المواطنين أجبروا على النزوح إلى
الأراضي الروسية وأن 14000 طفل في عداد
المفقودين
ومات الملايين من الناس في العديد من
المجاعات  التي أثارتها روسيا في هذا
البلد خلال القرن الماضي هي
مسألة نقاش بين المؤرخين
وسوف يناقش محامو حقوق الإنسان ما إذا كان
ما يحدث اليوم يمكن
تعريفه على أنه إبادة جماعية أم لا ، ولكن ليس هناك
شك في أنه على مدى المائة
عام الماضية كانت العلاقة بين
كانت موسكو وأوكرانيا قاتمة ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى إبادتهما حتى لا يتبقى
أي شخص عندها فقط يمكن أن
يكون هناك أي سلام
لمساعدة المجهود الحربي التي تربطها الخيش
بالشباك لجعل القناصة تمويه ،
ولكن قد يكون ضحكها هو الذي أبقى
عليها.  سنوات عديدة
سام كايلي سي إن إن
[موسيقى]